muchas gracias buenos días
bueno me siento honrado de ser el único
hombre acá parado en este escenario
muchísimas gracias y quiero hablarles
acerca del poder de la co-creación tanto
del sufrimiento como de la felicidad y
quiero hacerlo quiero empezar con una
historia les contaban historias en su
niñez se han dado cuenta que muchas de
las historias tienen la misma estructura
el mismo conflicto y el mismo final la
víctima sufre a causa de un monstruo
bien el héroe salvador a rescatar a la
princesa víctima mata al monstruo se
casa con la princesa y termina la
historia con un y fueron felices para
pero en la historia griega de teseo y
arianna el final es diferente
en creta vivía encerrado en un laberinto
bajo tierra un monstruo llamado el
minotauro que tenía cabeza de toro y
cuerpo humano una vez al año le daban
jóvenes para que se compara que se los
coma y se calme como ya casi no existían
jóvenes
ariadna hija del rey minos iba a ser el
próximo alimento del monstruo deseo hijo
del rey de atenas fue a creta a matar al
monstruo y el rey vino le dijo si matas
al monstruo te casarás con mi hija
arianna le dio un hilo a deseo para que
pueda entrar a laberinto y luego pueda
salir de él y teseo entró mató al
monstruo salió y se fue atenas con
ariadna para casarse y ser felices para
siempre pero se detuvieron un momento en
la isla de nassos y en ese lugar deseo
abandono
arianna por siempre
qué pasó
es porque teseo es hombre y todos los
hombres son iguales
estarían ahora víctima de teseo podemos
pasarnos horas o insultando a teseo pero
no hay tiempo
y con esta pregunta de qué paso se
inició mi investigación de mi tesis de
maestría revise muchísimos autores
muchísimas versiones algunas opuestas
entre sí y quiero compartir mi
interpretación libre que quizás nos
ayude a cambiar nuestra mirada la
primera pregunta que me hice fue acerca
de este círculo de la víctima el
victimario y el salvador es real por
ejemplo deseo no buscaba el amor
buscaba el reconocimiento de su padre
porque éste lo abandonó cuando era un
niño el mató al monstruo para que su
padre lo reconozca como hijo y fue el
rey minos el que dijo que si lo lograba
se casaba con su hija
ariadna
también fue abandonada por su madre
conde era una niña
alguien que nunca decidía nada en su
vida el destino se le imponían los otros
y ella tampoco buscaba el amor ella
quería escapar de la isla y por eso le
dio el hilo a teseo para que pueda
escapar del laberinto
y el minotauro era medio hermano de
ariana tampoco sabemos si se le iba a
comer
de repente solamente esperaba su hermana
y ella nunca se atrevió a buscarlo
pero si miramos al monstruo con otros
ojos
descubrimos a un niño que fue rechazado
desde que nació por ser diferente
y porque fue producto de una infidelidad
de la reina
y esto le dio tanta rabia al rey minos
que decidió encerrar a este niño
diferente en una prisión laberíntica
bajo las tierras secretas
y el niño creció
en furia y en fuerza
y un día
comenzó a dar en vistes en las columnas
de la ciudad de creta para
y todo el mundo actuaba como si nada
pasara
y todo el mundo minimizaba la amenaza
y el rey supo que tenía que hacer algo
que creen que fue a ver a ese niño que
él había encerrado bajo tierra creen que
fue o se atrevió a enfrentar las
consecuencias de sus actos pues no
decidió aliviar la furia del monstruo
sacrificó a 14 adolescentes para que se
los coma y se calme sacrifico lo más
puro que tenía en la ciudad antes que
enfrentar el verdadero problema que
vivía bajo tierra
y un día apareció teseo para matar un
drama ajeno
y teseo entró en el laberinto
con su espada en la mano derecha
y el hilo en la izquierda
y estaba preparado para enfrentar
cualquier tipo de pelea menos para ver a
un ser que sin defenderse le dijo
te están esperando mátame
por favor
ver
a un ser cansado de sufrir eternamente
bajo tierra lo cambió para siempre
al matar lo mató la polarización que
existía en él ya no sabía quién era el
bueno y quién era el malo
mientras salía del laberinto decidió
romper con este círculo de la víctima el
victimario del salvador y hacerse cargo
de su destino
quizá por eso abandono ariana para ser
protagonista de su vida
y el abandono a eso despertara vianda
porque ella también dejó su posición de
víctima decidió hacerse cargo de su
destino y se fue a celebrar la vida y
luego se convirtió en la constelación de
ariana
y el minotauro su hermano se volvió
parte de la constelación de tauro y
desde ahí nos enseña que todos tenemos
luz y sombra si rechazas tu sombra y le
esconden bajo tierra o crearás tu
sufrimiento y el de todo tu entorno
mi vida se parece mucho a esta historia
yo también me he sentido víctima con
mariana preguntándome por qué a mi
salvador como teseo generando relaciones
de dependencia
y también me sentí un monstruo como el
minotauro causando mucho daño
a los 40 años sentía frustrado con mi
vida profesional y personal
y decidir romper con este círculo y
hacer un cambio radical y poder
atreverme a hacer lo que siempre había
querido de que empecé a actuar y
mientras yo ya era psicólogo poder
entregar integrar la actuación y la
psicología en un emprendimiento y forme
mi empresa consultores en recursos
humanos y es un cambio radical pero todo
empezó tratando de entender quién es lo
que yo he vivido y eso fue el inicio de
una investigación lo que les voy a
presentar ahora son conceptos pero que
han surgido de mirarme por dentro que
fue como el hilo de ariadna que me
permitió entrar a mi laberinto interior
para salir y ser protagonista de mi vida
y la base de mi investigación es
entender la co-creación
o crear es crear con el otro una
creación conjunta tanto consciente o
inconsciente y descubrí que todos
participamos en la co-creación de
nuestro sufrimiento y nuestra felicidad
vamos a entender primero en la
co-creación del sufrimiento el primer
paso que nos hace entrar en el laberinto
es la polarización de nuestra percepción
dividir el mundo en buenos y malos
enfrentados entre víctimas victimarios y
salvadores rechazando nuestra propia
sombra y volviéndonos expertos en ver
sombras ajenas este trabajo lo han
desarrollado muchos autores en especial
karman que lo definió como el triángulo
dramático yo creo que más que triángulo
es un círculo
y lo importante de esto y es importante
aclarar lo que una cosa es ser víctima
de una situación peligrosa para tu vida
y otra electrizante por ejemplo un
asalto horrible y de pronto vas a tu
casa y en tu familia todo está más
cariñoso que nunca de pronto todos los
compañeros de tu oficina te llaman y de
pronto recibe tanta atención que dices
oye sabes que creo que voy a sufrir un
poquito más
esto me ha gustado y comienzas a estirar
como chicle el sufrimiento y pasan 5
años y dice este es el día que me
robaron no he dejado de sufrir porque
obtiene es una ganancia secundaria por
victimizar t la atención de los demás
por ejemplo y si hay victimización
entonces hay victimarios los malos y los
salvadores que se creen dioses en la
tierra el segundo paso que nos hace
quedar atrapados en el laberinto es el
condicionamiento aprendemos a reaccionar
a partir de nuestra percepción
polarizada
los seres humanos tenemos un lado humano
y un lado animal
tenemos una neo corteza que está encima
del cerebro con funciones superiores que
sólo los humanos tenemos pero también
tenemos una sub corteza con funciones
que compartimos con los animales la sub
corteza nos ayuda a sobrevivir cuando
percibimos peligro de muerte en ese
momento se activa nuestro mecanismo de
supervivencia y tenemos tres reacciones
rápidas y efectivas según la
circunstancia podemos atacar podemos
huir o de pronto nos quedamos
paralizados como en el asalto que quizás
sea la única reacción que nos produce
que nos hace sobrevivir
el problema surge cuando nos portamos
como el minotauro teniendo nuestro lado
animal encima de nuestro lado humano y
utilizamos nuestros mecanismos de
supervivencia física para el dolor
emocional a veces protegemos nuestro ego
más que a nuestro propio cuerpo y en ese
momento utilizamos estas reacciones de
supervivencia y nos enredamos en un
laberinto emocional de pura reactividad
entonces la parálisis se vuelve
sacrificio voy a cargar con todo el
dolor propio y ajeno y el ataque se
vuelve un comportamiento conflictivo me
voy a pelear con todo aquel que me
produce dolor y la huida se vuelve un
comportamiento evasor me escapo de
cualquier situación de dolor que perciba
y con estas 3 precepción es polarizadas
y estos tres comportamientos reactivos
se forma luego una búsqueda interior
profunda el laberinto de creta se los
presentó ahí está
por ejemplo ariana se colocó en la
posición de la víctima sacrificada
llamada la sufrida y el minotauro en la
posición del victimario conflictivo
llamado el explosivo y deseo como el
salvador conflictivo llamado el
justiciero pero luego teseo vio el
minotauro como el victimario sacrificado
llamado el culposo y ariadna vio a teseo
como el victimario evasor llamado el
sinvergüenza y quizás ariadna se coloca
en la posición de la víctima conflictiva
llamada la vengativa queriendo vengarse
de teseo entendieron no importa es un
laberinto
y podemos seguir ocupando roles y más
roles y seguir enredando nos en este
laberinto o creando nuestro sufrimiento
porque nunca entramos solos al laberinto
arrastramos a los demás para no hacernos
cargo de nuestra propia vida
cómo podemos salir pues primero
aceptar y hacerte cargo de la cocreación
un ejemplo de mi trabajo como consultor
de empresas el clima laboral he visto
tanta polarización y tanta victimización
por no aceptar que el clima es una co
creación de todos he visto trabajadores
resentidos con algún jefe viéndolo como
malo y esos mismos trabajadores
agrediendo a otros compañeros como él o
creando el mal clima laboral
otro ejemplo una decepción amorosa
horrible que haces puede decidir
vengarte tu próxima pareja
o puede decidir sanarte si decides
vengarte
colocas un eslabón más en esta cadena de
la co-creación del sufrimiento afectando
a tu entorno si decides sanarte rompes
con la cadena o creando tu felicidad
porque nadie tiene el poder de quitarte
el derecho de ser feliz solo lo tienes
tú
el budismo dice que el dolor es
inevitable el sufrimiento es opcional el
sufrimiento es una pelea con el dolor
cuando no aceptas la co-creación te
peleas con el dolor y surge el
sufrimiento y así como la sub corteza
nos ayuda a sobrevivir cuando hay dolor
emocional podemos usar la neocorteza
para aprender a vivir
y dejar de ver el dolor como un enemigo
y verlo como un maestro que nos enseña a
crecer como seres humanos y en ese
momento podemos dejar de reaccionar al
dolor y comenzar a responder a él saben
cómo se llama responder con habilidad y
responsabilidad bonito no pasar de la
reactividad a la responsabilidad y esto
sólo es posible cuando aceptas y ves
cómo estás interviniendo en la
co-creación de tu sufrimiento y el de
los demás
el siguiente paso que nos permite salir
el laberinto es atravesar el camino de
perdonar
que es como el hilo ariana
dificilísimo
tuve que aceptar que tengo luz y sombra
para poder perdonar
pero también pedir perdón y sobre todo
perdonarme
perdonarte
cuando sales del laberinto te vuelves
protagonista de tu vida y escoges la
montaña de la vida que quiere subir un
alpinista cuando está frente a una
montaña es absurdo porque se está
quejando no la dice pero quien apoya
esta montaña tan empinada lo que quien
apoyó está piel casi no se enfocó en un
ascensor por favor es absurdo no pero
cuando tú sientes que tu vida no es
producto de tus decisiones te quejas de
todos nos quejamos de todo y saben que
eso pasa porque no hemos definido un
propósito en nuestra vida ahí está
reconozco que a veces sigo entrando al
laberinto pero como conozco la salida
paso menos tiempo y pasó más tiempo
subiendo las montañas de la vida porque
la vida es una cordillera suben montañas
bajas montañas y el dolor sigue
apareciendo pero ha cambiado
radicalmente mi relación con el dolor sé
que dura un tiempo pero en ese tiempo
voy a aprender lo que haya que aprender
perdonar lo que haya que perdonar y
agradecer a ese dolor por las lecciones
y regalos que me trae
porque cuando aceptamos nuestro poder co
creador lo potenciamos lo desarrollamos
podemos pasar del sobrevivir al arte de
vivir
ser artistas de nuestra propia vida y en
tu vida hay otros artistas que
intervienen en tu obra tu familia tus
seres queridos tus amigos pero la
responsabilidad final de la obra siempre
siempre es tuya porque tu vida
es tu obra de arte
gracias
[Aplausos]